So, I'm on the Udacity Facebook page.
It's got some interesting stories, looking down there's Sebastian,
there's Jessica.
Oh, there's me.
But what happens when I scroll down even further?
We can see that I've got some room to go, and I can keep scrolling down,
scrolling down, scrolling down.
And, we can tell that this page isn't infinitely long.
But, what happens if I go all the way down to the bottom?
All of a sudden, look,
the scroll bar jumps up, and there's stories where there weren't any before.
Let's do it again.
Oh, and there we go.
We see that stories keep appearing even though this page isn't reloading.
Facebook accomplishes this through the use of Ajax requests.
Let's go ahead and open up dev tools to see what's going on behind the scenes.